oh boy
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video we'll be reviewing dutch
american tv personality and former model
yolanda hadid but first of all let me
pop in here to tell you about my sponsor
ritual so first of all i'm not pregnant
anymore and at the time of filming this
i'm finally nearing the end of my
breastfeeding journey but i know how
many of you are trying to conceive are
already pregnant or are recently
postpartum and are looking to maintain
your health during this new phase of
life now i know the supplement world is
really overwhelming but i like rituals
prenatal because first of all it's third
party tested and it has 12 high quality
nutrients like methylated fourth
generation folate vegan b12 d3 and
omega-3
now ritual is all about focusing their
multivitamins on the nutrients you
actually need rather than throwing in
everything about the kitchen sink and
they're really transparent about where
they source their nutrients and why as
well as their environmental impact so
for example they use 100 recycled
materials in their packaging and their
mailers are made from recycled newsprint
and plant fibers their multi is also
vegan gluten free and allergen-free with
no colorants added sugar additives or
enlisted ingredients and these ones have
a delayed release capsule design to help
prevent nausea they also have a regular
multivitamin for men and women as well
as a 50-plus option but it's super
convenient because they just deliver it
to your door as part of a subscription
so even when you're having super mom
brain you won't run out so if you want
to try it out you can use my promo code
and check out the link in the
description to get 10 off of your first
three months of ritual now of course you
can pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating i'm going to be
talking about macros and calories and a
lot of triggering things so please feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and of course
if you're new here don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
little bell so that you never miss out
on an episode now very quickly for those
who don't know yolanda hadid is a model
turned tv personality best known for her
appearance on the real housewives of
beverly hills and the fact that she's
the mom to famous models gigi bella and
anwar hadid i mean i guess she's got
good genes a ton
of you have not only asked me to review
her bite-sized interview on harper's
bazaar but also the infamous videos of
her talking about food with her kids so
let's kick things off by taking a quick
look at her diet
you are what you eat it's just a fact
but that doesn't mean that in my
household we don't have pizzas flying
around sometimes or hamburgers okay i'm
just going to jump right in here folks
because i don't know first of all i need
to just say that i have never been a fan
of the whole you are what you eat mantra
it's actually kind of a
misinterpretation of the original quote
and i also feel like it's moralizing
sentiments like this
that assign self value and worth to
something as primitive and fundamental
as food now at its most literal
translation it's kind of ridiculous like
if i eat an apple am i an apple no
obviously not but if we look at a more
general interpretation yes of course the
foods that we eat contribute to the
health of our cells and therefore our
body but it's really important to note
that who we are even from just a
physical health perspective is
incredibly complex it cannot be reduced
down to the food that we eat and it
absolutely cannot be reduced to just
personalized choice or
lifestyle i also don't really like the
insinuation that how or what you eat is
an indicator of like the kind of person
that you are and even though it's not
explicitly stated a lot of people who
use language like this are kind of
suggesting that you know if you eat
processed junk food you know you're lazy
stupid and imprudent and if you eat
wholesome organic food you're morally
righteous and disciplined and i just
think that this thinking is so elitist
identity should be so much more than
non-gmo organic gluten-free bread so
obviously a big mac and an apple are not
nutritionally equal but we can make them
morally equal by changing the language
that we use to describe food and not
trying to justify our health or life
outcomes exclusively by
personal choice anyways thank you for
coming to my ted talk i am happy to hear
that she said that they still have pizza
and hamburgers occasionally so let's see
what else she has to say but i also
think that as a mom we leave by example
so i continue to do all my organic
healthy stuff okay so yes i agree that
as parents we do lead by example parents
are usually the primary role models in
our kids lives especially when it comes
to something that we're doing multiple
times a day like eating so this is why i
always say that like if you want your
kids to eat vegetables it's imperative
that they see you eat them too hard stop
but this role modeling with regards to
our relationship with food goes the
other way as well so if your kids see
and hear you talk about conventional
vegetables being toxic or that pizza
makes you fat or that they shouldn't
have a second helping of mashed potatoes
if they want to look a certain way
you're putting your kids at risk of a
very complicated and unhealthy
relationship with food so research
suggests that kids whose mothers have an
eating disorder or who display
disordered eating patterns have a
significantly increased risk of
disordered eating themselves
obviously and that's because restriction
becomes the dominant narrative in the
home
it's normalized and in a lot of cases
it's encouraged
like obviously i'm very passionate about
this myself and i have a lot more to say
about it but i'm going to dive more
deeper into it in just a bit let's see
what else she has to eat you know i like
to start my morning with a glass of
lemon water i mean obviously lemon water
i'm the queen of lemons
just because they have so many health
benefits it alkalizes the the gut it's
cleansing it has a lot of nutrients in
it so it's just a great way to start
your morning okay guys this video is
from 2018
and now i'm kind of even more annoyed
thinking that yolanda maybe created the
spark that started this dumpster fire of
a wellness trend folks folks folks
listen lemons are delicious they add
flavor to mundane water and i guess a
little vitamin c so let's be real most
people having lemon water in the morning
probably don't actually need more of
that but it does not alkalinize the gut
we have a pretty intense ph regulatory
mechanism in the body also i don't know
why you would want to alkalinize the gut
anyways because if you actually think
about it you kind of want an acidic gut
so that food can get broken down and
you're not trying to poop out big chunks
of food also for the love of all that is
holy
no
it does not cleanse you any more than
plain old water would make you go pee
or take a dump um
can i go take a dump
yeah okay that's cool all water is good
water flavor it how you like it and
let's move on makes sense to me you know
i don't really drink coffee i love
matcha with goat milk so i usually do
that but always maybe like 15 minutes
after i have my lemon water gosh why are
we gonna make hydration so complicated i
cannot imagine having to think so much
about the precise timing of
when i can eat what
especially when there's zero scientific
basis for this ritual but anyways matcha
with goat's milk sounds awesome
you guys know i do not comment on
people's coffee rituals like you have it
how you like it there's always bigger
fish to fry but i'm gonna speak more
about goat's milk in a bit so definitely
stay tuned if you want the 411 on that
but i'm hungry so let's eat after my
lemon water i do
oatmeal and then i really think that we
don't have enough fat anymore in our
diet so i always put a little bit of
organic butter i like to put a little
bit of almonds on it
right now i'm into strawberries
sometimes i put organic honey but then i
also like to use stevia and if you can
get used to the taste i think it's a
much better and healthier choice than
white sugar okay so here we have a
classic oatmeal bowl
we've got fiber-rich carbs in the oats
and strawberries
fat in the organic butter and almonds
and a little bit of protein in the
almonds yolanda says that she adds the
almonds for protein which it does
contain but in that portion we're only
looking at like two to three grams so
there's actually probably more protein
in the oats themselves to be honest so
if we wanted to bump up the satiety
factor i would want to add a little bit
more protein in there either by adding
in some whipped egg whites as i do in my
protest or some silken tofu for a vegan
option or of course you could mix in
some protein powder i also find it
strange that her rationale for choosing
strawberries is because they are low in
sugar but then she proceeds to top her
oats with honey a few things here first
to clarify my stance i don't think that
the sugar in the honey or the
strawberries is something to be
concerned about so if you like honey on
your oats add honey i'm not demonizing
honey or any sugar especially when
adding it to something nutrient dense
like oats i'm just trolling this choice
because of hypocrisy in her statement if
we're talking about limiting sugar in
our diet we really want to be focusing
mainly on limiting what we call free
sugars and those are sugars that are not
bound up with fiber protein or fat
aka the hunger crushing combo
so honey even though it's natural and in
yolanda's case likely organic it still
is considered to be a free sugar so it's
definitely more likely to spike your
blood sugar compared to something like a
strawberry or even a higher sugar fruit
like cherries because it comes bound up
with fiber to help minimize the glycemic
load now i also see that she mixes it
with stevia so there's more sweetness
there as well which again is totally
fine i actually have a whole video on
sweeteners that you can check out right
here but as always my take home message
for all sources of sweet is whether you
like white sugar honey stevia or
aspartame
choose the option that you actually
enjoy and just aim to use it sparingly
and in moderation i also think it's
important to take your time
to eat breakfast you know you can do it
in 10 minutes it doesn't need to be an
hour but just this moment where you
just
check in with yourself okay so i really
love this and ideally we would want to
be checking in with ourself at every
meal if we can of course i have to
acknowledge the privilege in
recommending that everyone take time out
of their morning to sit down
uninterrupted and peacefully for a
beautiful meal to look out the window
and express their gratitude for the food
and for nature etc i mean a lot of us
are in survival mode in the morning and
well like the rest of the day as well
but research suggests that mindful
eating can actually calm the nervous
system
and can help with the digestion of our
food due to the brain gut axis not to
mention also it allows us to better tune
in with our hunger and fullness cues as
we eat so yes if and when we can making
mealtimes a priority is a really healthy
plan so for lunch i always like to have
a salad and
some sort of protein today i'm gonna do
a arugula salad i'd like to make a curry
chicken mayo and onions and celery and
all that stuff this combination of
brussels sprouts cranberries a little
bit of that on it and then just a little
bit of dressing that i made with olive
oil honey a little vinegar okay so this
looks absolutely divine we have protein
from the chicken fat from the mayo and
vinaigrette and lots of fiber in the
brussels sprouts and greens now i would
probably want to see a little curve
action in here just to bump up the
satiety factor especially because i
would say that the protein portion also
wasn't huge so maybe adding in some
toast on the side or some cooked quinoa
sweet potatoes or other whole grain into
the mix but i also acknowledged that she
had a higher carb breakfast so
these things do tend to balance
themselves out
it just comes down to ensuring that this
still helps her meet her overall daily
needs
and so far we've got two
relatively light meals so
yeah i guess we'll have to see how this
shakes out i also want to quickly note
that there seems to be a really huge
preoccupation with everything being
organic like she has to call it out as
being organic and there's absolutely
some value in choosing organics i'm not
going to get into too much detail here
because it's a huge topic and we would
be here all day but i did discuss it in
more detail in my sorel amore video
right here but those benefits in my
opinion are predominantly more
environmental and in some cases worker
welfare so my take on when it comes to
organics is i would much rather see
people choose more conventional fruits
and vegetables than fewer organic fruits
and vegetables choose what you can
afford and feel good about that choice
so my favorite afternoon little snack
like a little pick-me-up is a goat milk
i'm obsessed with cardamon and cinnamon
and i boil that stir it and then i
sweeten it with honey
i love it so that looks super cozy and
makes me equally excited and distressed
about the fact that winter is around the
corner for us canadians winter is coming
i know to my southern followers that
probably sounds insane but show me a
turtleneck or a puffer vest and i
automatically get a little ptsd from the
last big storm that we had and i feel
the need to start panic christmas
shopping but anyways
gotta live in the now and enjoy these
warm months while we can
but yeah this does sound super
comforting and delicious
again yolanda opts for goat's milk which
she says she finds easier to digest than
cow's milk so since i didn't bug her
about her coffee tea ritual
let's unpack that choice right now now
there are a number of reasons why some
people potentially tolerate goat's milk
better than cow's milk dairy
so first of all
goat's milk contains much less about 90
percent less of the a1 beta casein
protein compared to traditional dairy
milk which usually contains a mixture of
a1 and a2 casein protein unless you're
choosing 100 a2 milk of course but the
a1 protein is often thought to be
responsible for some people's digestive
issues with milk now two goat's milk
contains slightly smaller fat globules
compared to cow's milk about 2.6
micrometers versus 3.5 micrometers in
diameter respectively so some experts
have speculated that these smaller fat
globules make it easier for our bodies
to break down
but we also don't have solid evidence to
substantiate this theory finally goat's
milk has slightly less lactose than
cow's milk but the difference is
admittedly negligible about 11 grams
versus 12 grams per cup
so it is unlikely to contribute to major
differences in tolerance particularly
for those who can tolerate some lactose
in their diet so this all theoretically
makes sense as a rationale for why you
might digest goat's milk better than
cows however in real life studies
suggest that when comparing the
digestion of these two options side by
side they don't seem to majorly affect
digestive discomfort so it might
actually be kind of an individual thing
all that said if you personally find
that drinking goat's milk or any kind of
milk for that matter makes you feel good
then that's great
drink that goat's milk is still a really
great source of protein and other
essential nutrients so i do think it is
a great choice but of course just keep
in mind that what works for one person
won't universally work for all
so i like to make my dinner my lightest
meal of the day only because i go to
sleep very early so it doesn't give you
much time to digest anything else okay
so i don't think it's a bad idea to
focus on front loading our calories
earlier on in the day when we can so we
do have research that metabolically
folks that front load their calories
tend to have better insulin sensitivity
while those who eat the bulk of their
calories in the evening or at night tend
to have a lower insulin sensitivity as
for digestion if you struggle with acid
reflux or gerd then yes the
recommendation is to try not to eat
anything too heavy about three hours
before bed but most people otherwise can
have like a snack or meal
of course a little bit closer to bedtime
especially one that isn't super high in
fat or greasy what seems to be more
important for sleep purposes
is making sure that you've actually
eaten
enough as obviously hunger not
surprisingly can be a much greater sleep
disturber than digesting a slightly
bigger meal but ultimately you kind of
have to find a pattern of eating that
feels best to you
and meets your own circadian rhythm and
routine but of course i'm just kind of
sharing what the evidence to date has to
say let's see what she's eating
so i love to do any kind of soup started
with an organic chicken broth chopped
garlic chopped carrots onions of course
celery zucchini salt and pepper
i like to use himalayan salt just
because there's so many great minerals
in there little baby kale i don't cook
it too long because i don't want to
overcook it this is bragg's natural
yeast and i love the flavor of that okay
so this soup looks delicious it is
raining hard today
and so i'm craving soup myself but we've
got some organic chicken broth from a
carton we've got garlic carrots onions
celery zucchini himalayan salt and
pepper some baby kale and nutritional
yeast i like that we've got tons of
fiber rich veg and a little protein in
the nutritional yeast but honestly not a
whole lot else so this would be a lovely
side dish
but even for a light meal it's really
just not enough particularly in the
context of the rest of her day i would
want to see more carbs protein and fat
in here so she could throw in a can of
white beans and maybe some shortcut
pasta to make like a minestrone style
soup and then serve it with some
crostini drizzled in olive oil that to
me would be a light meal that would
still have more substance going on as
for the himalayan salt
as i've discussed in my video on ian's
summer holder right here
yes it does have greater amounts of some
beneficial electrolytes when compared to
table salt three times potassium 100
times the magnesium and four times the
calcium per gram but i don't recommend
using salt specifically to get more of
those nutrients into your diet like you
would need to consume
1250 grams or 250 teaspoons of salt to
meet your potassium needs so yeah you'd
be much better off getting that from
fruits and vegetables as for her comment
about not overcooking her soup it is
definitely smart to try to limit how
long you're cooking your veg so research
suggests that cooking does reduce the
micronutrient levels of most vegetables
though in some cases cooking can
actually enhance nutrients like lycopene
in tomatoes for example but generally
speaking steaming your vegetables is
really the most nutrient-friendly
cooking method as it seems to have
minimal effects on chlorophyll soluble
proteins vitamin c and glucosinolates
boiling especially for like 30 to 40
minutes as she did here
would result in significantly more
nutrient loss so i would definitely
suggest cooking only long enough to
soften those vegetables and then putting
the greens in like at the last minute
just to wilt them down on a proper night
when everybody's home on time i mean
they love their spaghetti bolognese
garlic bread salad but this will do you
know for a late dinner so that sounds
like a much more sufficient balanced
meal and i know it's hard as a mom not
to take the time to feed ourselves
properly when maybe our kids are not in
the house but i would say as an act of
self-care we also deserve to eat full
meals we also need more than like a
small bowl of vegetable soup or like a
basic cereal bowl before we go to bed
and it doesn't need to be complicated
like
literally like i said adding a piece of
bread to this or throwing in a can of
beans would already be a huge
improvement to this meal so if you're a
parent
and you know that your kids deserve and
need full balanced meals try to also
remind yourself that you do too but yeah
wow
apparently that's all she's eating today
so i guess let's move on to the stats
now it's always difficult to estimate
someone's calories from their day of
eating through these videos but based on
my rough calculations yolanda's
approximate daily caloric intake based
off of this day comes out as just 1200
to 1300 calories which is well below her
energy needs she also is deficient in
all three major macronutrients plus
she's low in vitamin d iron and fiber
and that all is really not surprising to
me because it's just not a lot of food
we saw just three meals all of which
were quite small and then only a little
goat's milk for a snack this is just not
enough to help any woman thrive so i do
have a few quick and dirty tips to help
yolanda bump this up first of all at
breakfast i would love to see some
protein in the mix so we can make this
protest like i mentioned or pair the
bowl with some eggs now lunch i'd love a
little bread or some whole grains in the
salad and at dinner
i'd love to see more of pretty much
everything that bowl of vegetable soup
probably had 100 calories max so yeah it
may be easy to digest but you know
what's also really easy to digest water
and that is largely what that was water
with a little bit of fiber and not much
else so yeah like i said digesting a
heavy meal can absolutely interfere with
sleep but so can ravenous hunger i would
also love to see her goat's milk lattes
paired with something else to help her
simply add some more calories into her
day so it could be like a piece of fruit
yogurt a handful of nuts or just a
simple granola bar it does not need to
be complicated but i think at this point
really any extra calories would help now
i know it's somewhat hard to believe but
i think we have
bigger issues than what yolanda is
eating
or more accurately not eating it's time
to talk about yolanda's relationship to
food there are unfortunately a number of
viral videos going around over talking
to her now famous children about food
from her days on the real housewives of
beverly hills let's take a look and
trigger warning volleyball is a very
masculine sport
modeling is a very feminine thing
and that means sometimes we have to give
up things that we love to do so their
bodies are big and bulky and i mean they
eat like like man i wanted her to
develop as a woman i thought that my
daughter was a lesbian i don't even know
where or
how to begin first of all what decade is
this why are we genderizing activities
volleyball is masculine and their bodies
are big and bulky and to play it
people eat like men or if you're not a
man now you're a lesbian i can't even
begin to count the ways
that this is wrong first of all
sport or no sport models or no models
our young teens deserve to eat enough
calories to sustain their daily activity
and growth
we should not be restricting foods or
types of foods to try to mold our kids
into a certain body type restriction in
childhood is dangerous and it actually
can often increase the risk of weight
gain
not just disordered eating one famous
twin study which is pretty much the gold
standard in nutrition research
found that dieting teen twins were more
likely to become obese compared to their
non-dieting counterparts second are
volleyball players big and bulky i don't
think it's appropriate to be criticizing
our own or other people's bodies in
front of our children period and i never
think it's appropriate to criticize our
kids bodies never ever but how skewed a
perception is this i'm not even gonna
get into stereotypical body types for
different sports but i will just say
that athletes who play specific sports
are likely much more interested in
supporting the muscles that they need to
excel at their sport rather than
worrying about trying to make a body
part look a certain way obviously this
may not be true for some aesthetic
sports but
volleyball like you're gonna build upper
body muscles that you need to perform
third there is no such thing as eating
like a man or eating like a lady
patriarchal gendered assumptions drive
young women to feel self-conscious or
shame about feeding their body basic
balanced meals that do not just consist
of lettuce and green juice you need
protein fat carbs and yes calories to
move your body on a runway on a
volleyball court
and just in any other scenario in real
life even brushing your teeth requires
more energy than your basal metabolic
rate which for a teenager is
minimum 1500 calories and that is basal
fyi not what you would actually need to
eat in a day which is likely closer to
2500 calories and four what kind of
homophobic [ __ ] is assuming that a
young girl who wants to play a sport is
gay no
do better yolanda oh
ah
i'm so excited for the food
pretty much all the food that we're
eating is like a heart attack and a meal
it's like
but it's gonna be so good it's good you
can have one one night of being bad
right i was actually really good this
week yeah and then you got to get back
in your diet though because you know in
paris and milan they like to keep the
girls just a tad on the skinny side i
feel so sad for gigi like she has
clearly already ingrained some of these
extreme die culture messages calling out
delicious food as a heart attack and
that she's being so good while her mom
allows her to have one night of being
bad as long as she gets back on her diet
right after i don't care if you ate an
entire cake you are not bad because of
it and it's one thing to encourage a
restrictive diet under the guise of
healthy eating which is obviously
problematic in this case but probably
also kind of out of good intentions and
some ignorance on yolanda's part but to
explicitly encourage your daughter to be
skinny because that's how they like
their models in europe
is knowingly encouraging harm and
sickness for the sake of money and fame
it's hard to
exercise six days a week and it's hard
to not eat any sugar and it's hard to
have to eat salad every day gigi's in
charge of her own diet but to be on your
best way you got to make the right
choice i feel sick watching this like i
actually feel sick it is so sad to me
that yolanda needs to push her own
dysfunctional relationship with food
onto her daughter and is controlling her
exposure and access to
bad food as a way to manipulate her
weight i'm not sure how old gigi is in
this clip but she is now 26 years old
and she's a mom herself to her own baby
girl so i can only hope that her mother
is not still manipulating her access to
food i also hope for the sake of her own
daughter's health that she's able to
stop this pattern now both in herself
and in her mom when her child is around
but when a child is being raised in a
household with constant restriction
surveillance and body checking they risk
growing into adults with little to no
eating competency and this often is the
jumping off point for disordered eating
and severe eating disorders hoarding
hiding binging in secret extreme food
cravings and associating meeting your
basic needs with shame guilt and fear
that's what can happen here honestly
this compilation was terrifying to me
and i'm sure as a mom who wants her kids
to have a healthy balanced diet that is
not the outcome that yolanda is seeking
so if you're struggling with your
relationship with food yourself and
you're trying to make sure this isn't
passed on to the next generation
here are a few super top level tips one
don't talk about food in dichotomous
terms don't call it out as good or bad
don't talk about your body or your kid's
body in a negative way
and don't connect eating a certain food
or not eating a certain food
with your weight
two make fun foods available
don't restrict them or make them so
special that our kids become obsessed
integrate them into meals and snacks
regularly i actually personally always
offer a small kids kid-sized portion of
something sweet with my son's meal
on the same plate as the rest of his
meal and three prioritize family meals
and encourage your kids to listen to
their tummies to guide when they are
done
don't pressure don't praise as hard as
that might be i actually have a whole
video on raising an intuitive eater that
you can check out right here and i'll
also leave a link to a free downloadable
cheat sheet on my blog below
but back to yolanda and her kids now i
want to be empathetic that it would take
an enormous amount of introspection and
critical thinking to be able to escape
die culture in this case yolanda is a
former model and her daughters are
obviously also in the industry and diet
culture is rampant in these circles so
i'm sure it's like a total echo chamber
and a lot of these behaviors have been
completely normalized and encouraged for
their entire adult lives so to yolanda's
point as parents we have an enormous
responsibility and it's scary to be role
modeling good eating habits but our
relationship with food including how we
talk about it is just as important as
the specific foods that we eat and serve
and when the work life reinforces this
narrative and the home life also does it
can feel impossible to escape but it's
never too late to get woke to the damage
diet culture can do and i have to hope
that you land us now adult kids and now
also grandkid can find other role models
in their lives to counter this extreme
die culture messaging and i also hope
that seeing as these are old clips that
yolana herself has been able to identify
some of these deficiencies in this way
of thinking she seems to be a very
devoted mother but being a great mom
means helping ourselves first to be able
to help our kids in the long run and i
think that everyone would benefit from a
bit of a wake-up call on this and that
was a lot i know but thank you guys so
much for tuning in to today's video if
you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
who you'd like to see me review next
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye